last time I met astronaut Jessica Mary
she was training for her expedition to
the International Space Station seven
weightless months later she returned on
the 17th of April to the same planet but
a different world Jessica welcome back
toxic air there you've been now seven
months in orbit is it the same Jessica
that came back I'm not sure I think one
of the biggest things that still feels a
bit odd is that we've come back to a
completely different planet so whether
or not I've changed I'm not sure because
everything feels completely different
given the earth that I came back to you
came back you landed on April 17th
that's not a little more than two weeks
ago tell me tell me about that descent
how was that it was really good
phenomenal experience
I've heard it described many times from
my colleagues and of course we get a lot
of training on it as well so we feel
quite prepared knowing what to expect
and it was such an extraordinary
experience because everything was like
clockwork and it's really a testament to
how robust that Soyuz spacecraft is
exactly when I expected things to happen
you know because really as the crew the
commander and myself in the left seat is
a co-pilot we're monitoring everything
throughout the descent if things are
going nominally as we say if things are
going well then you really don't have to
take that much actual action you're
really monitoring things you are sending
some commands but you don't have to do
too much if the automatic systems are
working well but of course we are
trained to react to an emergency in
which we do need to take some more
action but it was so interesting to see
I mean everything was just happening
like clockwork
exactly what I expected it I would be
monitoring and there it was and then you
could really have a sense of how dynamic
everything was when you felt the
separation of the upper the habitation
module that's on the upper part that
actually burns up in the atmosphere and
only the descent module comes down you
could hear those there pyro bolts that
fire in order to separate those two
parts of the vehicle you could hear it
and you could
you know click click click and inches
away from my head I'm watching the
flames you know come past and it was
just a really really incredible
experience and then when the parachute
opens that is the most dynamic phase of
the flight and I was prepared for this
because everybody had told me about it
but nothing can really prepare you for
what it feels like since it's nothing
like anything I've ever experienced it's
not as if you're swaying when the risers
come out you're it's really motion and
everything in every direction as the
vehicle stabilized it's under the
parachute so you feel as if you're in a
washing machine or something every every
motion you can imagine is imparted on
your body and then that only lasts lasts
for a short time then you're falling
under the parachute and you're then
closely monitoring because you want to
be completely still and have all of your
seat belts very tight and be ready to
brace for the impact of the landing
itself and that I had been described to
me as feeling like a car crash since of
course you come to a sudden stop you
have these soft landing thrusters that
fire and then you get the ground so I
was prepared for a really jarring impact
you know we have had some experiences
where crew members will even get injured
because they don't have their seat belts
tight enough or a limb comes out and
knee comes out or something so I was
making sure that I was really well
positioned so I was expecting this big
jarring impact and actually I felt like
it was quite soft they call it a soft
landing and then suddenly were on the
ground and that was just such a strange
experience you know you're you're in
space you've been there for seven months
and suddenly you're back on the ground
in a field in the middle of Kazakhstan I
mean you're trained for this you you
probably you won't throw up right right
but I guess I would it depends you know
a lot of that is really individual so
some individuals even astronauts and
cosmonauts do still get quite sick and
coming back because as you might imagine
your neuro vestibular system has become
accustomed to microgravity and here on
earth really our vestibular systems have
evolved and are very gravity dependent
in terms of your stability your spacial
awareness it's more than that for me
it's just a strange feeling if
everything feels so heavy your body
feels so heavy you just feel like you're
being pulled down and that that is
actually I still feel like that a little
bit even
couple weeks in I went for a run today
and I've been doing some running we have
two hours of reconditioning every day
with our trainers in the gym and I've
been doing some running on the alter G
treadmill that we have which is
basically sports teams have them for
rehab it you you have a little skirt on
and it blows air up so it offsets some
of your weight so I've been running on
that a little bit but today I ran
outside in the heat in Houston with my
hundred percent body weight and I can
say it felt like about 310 percent body
weight because you're you're just not
used to that I think the motor neuron
connection as well as is altered still
from microgravity so your new normal is
is the the weightless the weightless
life yeah at least for a little bit
longer until my body kind of
reintegrates and it's really interesting
because we spend so much time exercising
on-orbit in order to maintain our bone
density and muscle mass and we spent two
and a half hours of our day lifting
weights and then doing cardiovascular
exercise like running or bicycling and
so you're in really good shape better
shape than when you left I'm lifting way
more weight than when I left I have
higher muscle mass but there's something
else going on with the cardiovascular
dynamic that running it's a very strange
thing and I think it's partially the
motor neuron connection as well from
your brain because you know I would feel
like I'm lifting my legs but what I what
I felt like I was doing in my brain
didn't feel the same way in in my muscle
so it's really interesting to see that
transition and that's the kind of thing
actually running is the one thing that
seems to take the longest to come back
tell me when you when you had landed and
you were in Kazakhstan how soon did the
corona situation become reality for you
yeah very soon because as soon as the
hatch was open and what happens is the
search and rescue teams come they
actually opened the hatch and we just
kind of stay where we are and wait for
them to come in and essentially pull us
out they don't want us to over exert
ourselves when we first land and it was
apparent from the very moment the hatch
was open because everybody that we saw
was wearing masks I mean I understand
that your immune system is weakened
right yeah that's right that's one of
the hallmarks physiologically of
spaceflight we do see this dysregulation
of the immune
system where we have a decrease in our
t-cells for example we have sometimes
astronauts experience reactivation of
latent viruses like the chickenpox virus
there's something about the microgravity
environment whether it's the stress or
other factors that do cause a disruption
of the immune system so they wanted to
be extra cautious with us given the
situation with koban 19 to make sure
that we didn't contract it right away
because they weren't so sure how our
immune systems would be able to respond
to it
luckily those things actually do come up
quite quickly and so that's why they
kept us in quarantine for a week they
were monitoring parameters like our
t-cells in order to see how how quickly
those systems were coming back and they
did come back to baseline levels within
a week what is is the ISS itself is that
a virus free environment totally it is
yeah we really aren't exposed to any
viruses for the entire duration that
we're up there which is a wonderful
thing it was wonderful to never worry
about having to get a cold or anything
like that you know of course the other
people are coming I mean they're you you
have all their else drones coming coming
in while you were there right right
that's right but one of the ways that we
try to get around that is that we do
have a quarantine period before launch
so before I launched in Kazakhstan for
example we were in a quarantine for
about two weeks before launch so that's
what they try to always do we do the
same a similar type of thing in the u.s.
to make sure that you're sending healthy
astronauts you have that two-week period
to make sure that nothing's gonna pop up
and then hopefully anybody that launches
won't be carrying anything up with them
looking up at the planet from the ISS
everything looks I guess beautiful and
as it always looks right then you get
these news about what's happening that
there is a pandemic it it was it
possible for you to fully understand
what was happening first of all like you
say I'm looking out the window and I'm
seeing this earth that is equally as
stunning and beautiful in every way as
it was before that and then to be
watching the news to be talking to our
loved ones at home and seeing this whole
situation unfold it was a little bit
difficult for us to believe that it was
happening because we were still very
busy in the earth beneath us was coming
to the
almost grinding halt but we were still
up there doing our same job every day
being very busy with the experiments
with the space station maintenance
everything that we were doing and it was
very strange to think we are only three
humans right now of the 7.5 billion
humans on earth we are only three of us
that are not affected by this right now
so we we heard the stories we saw what
was happening but it was difficult to
feel like it was reality it felt a
little bit surreal for us to be
witnessing it up from up there
you became a part of a historic
spacewalk the first biggest face book
you did you did many space go to 2 or 3
right I did 3 yep but but the first one
was historic because it was the first
all-female Facebook right it was yes I
mean there have been many other women of
course I don't have done spacewalks but
never two women at the same time and of
course it didn't mean a lot to a lot of
people on earth and that was something
that was actually quite overwhelming for
me I I was really surprised by the
magnitude of the response that we were
getting from the ground we received so
many messages from young girls or from
really any young person with a dream or
her adults as well saying how much of a
difference it made to them and how
inspired it made them and that that the
magnitude of that was certainly not lost
on us we felt so privileged to have that
extraordinary opportunity can you can
you even though it is an old females
baseball can you take me with you it was
definitely the highlight I would say of
my mission I look at those three
spacewalks as that was something I wish
I could have done even more have we were
incredibly fortunate to have done so
many in expedition 61 which were the was
the first four months of my mission we
did nine spacewalks in that period and
that is really much more than normal
normally in one mission like that you'll
have zero one or maybe two spacewalks
and we had nine just given the
circumstances and of course you know
being one of those being the first
all-female spacewalk and it was just
such an amazing experience something
that you never forget and the hatch
opens and you come outside and I look
down and I could see my boots and then
nothing else but the earth below and it
was just so
extraordinary and seeing the views that
we have from the space station at the
window of course incredible but it
looked even a little bit more crisp and
the colors even looked a little bit more
intense when you're only looking through
them through the thin visor no nothing
is separating you from the vacuum of
space except for this thin visor and
you're in this mini little
self-contained spacecraft of your own
really and that is just of course a very
intense experience I wish that during
our spacewalks we had more time to
really just appreciate that and to look
at the earth and look around but the
truth is that we're so busy getting the
task done that we need to do and it
really does it's completely
all-consuming of your concentration and
your focus because it is exhausting
physically and mentally in order to work
in that space suit so very quickly
you're focused on the task at hand but
have it I mean did it all did it all go
smooth but the both of you or did it did
it did that first spacewalk we were
incredibly lucky everything worked out
it was just one of those days where
nothing went wrong and that's you know
that's actually not normal normally
there's something you didn't expect and
this is hardware that's left out there
for years so it's undergone various
thermal cycles so sometimes bolts don't
cooperate or you don't know exactly what
to expect from the hardware we if
everything went really really well on
that first spacewalk what about Delta 2
yeah the the other two we actually did
have some unexpected things happen and
that was really interesting for us
because I think that's when your
training really kicks in when you have
an unanticipated situation you have to
be able to react to it and that we had
two instances one on the second
spacewalk there was a moment at the very
tour at the very beginning of the
spacewalk where suddenly no Christina
and I were separated by several feet and
I was actually on the other side of this
of this one pallet and she suddenly said
I you know I think there's something
wrong I think that my my lights have
become dislodged on the top of the
spacesuit we have a video camera and
lights and that's not something that's
supposed to come off outside and so hers
had become detached and I look over so I
make my way over to her
and I see it just dangling by one
electrical connection and it's floating
away from her and so we first attempted
to try to put it back on but it actually
is impossible to do that with all the
men there are some really intricate
mechanisms that you need to do so to be
able to do that with gloved hands was
actually impossible so what they but
what they had me do was actually detach
it from that cable so I did have to you
know very carefully remove this cable
and that was you know obviously quite
stressful given this was only my second
spacewalk and I'm trying to do something
that we're not even supposed to be able
to do with gloves but we managed to do
that and so Christina
conducted the rest of that spacewalk
essentially without lights which was
fine in when we had the sun shining but
of course every you know 45 minutes or
so so we're in complete darkness it was
an interesting experience for sure you
you you're both Americans and Russians
up there are there any no-go topics when
you when you just have your evening chit
chats yeah not really and you know of
course were more diverse than just
Americans and Russians we also had an
Italian crew member on board with us and
at other times during the mission we
have Japanese and Canadian crew members
too and I think that really those sort
of political issues though of course are
incredibly important for everybody on
the ground we really don't think that
way when we're in space you know we are
up there operating as one crew and and I
think it's easy very easy for us to have
that perspective when we look down on a
planet and we don't see those
geopolitical man-made boundaries and we
know that we really you know it's just
kind of the response that I felt when
having that perspective in relation to
Kovan 19 as well the looking down at the
planet from up there it is very easy for
us to see that we are all in this
together that we really are all one
humans and I think that's how we feel as
a crew you know I would say yeah you're
probably right we don't directly bring
up those topics about our political
situations on the ground but I don't
think it's you know it's not awkward
it's not really uncomfortable we're not
avoiding anything it's just not really
something that we're focused on how much
I'm Sweden did you bring up I had a
really large Swedish flag
a banner from Sock'em Zooniverse hit and
I had something from Westeros which is
where my grandmother is from where my
mother was from and a few other things I
have pipi long strip
book so pipi now finally she's been in
space absolutely I mean I think if any
female were gonna be the right Swedish
female to be in space its Pippi right
indeed absolutely do you I mean do you
do you miss it do you want to go back
yes I would go tomorrow if I could
well why is that what do you miss the
most I think you know what I've been
saying since I came back is gravity's
overrated and it is just this the
feeling of floating and the views
looking down at the planet and just
being part of all of that it was really
so powerful and I knew it at the time I
actually did want to stay longer not not
everybody feels that way there are quite
a few people that I would say coming to
the end of their approximately six-month
mission they're usually ready to go back
for me I would have rather had a longer
mission and I think especially given the
situation when all of the current
current situation on the ground was
happening of course that made it
slightly even slightly more less
desirable to return given us a choice
that we're turning into after being in
isolation for so many months and then
thinking okay now we're gonna go back to
earth and be in more isolation and and
personally I think it's much more
isolating and confining down here in
this present situation than it is on the
space station because that's us well
that's just part of our mission right we
know there's a very good reason why
we're I saluted because we are in a
spacecraft that we need a life support
system for we cannot survive in the
vacuum of space you know without a
spacesuit or without all of the luxuries
of the space station that we have and
because everything else is so
extraordinary all of the experiences
that we're having are so intense you
know I think that the isolation is just
really part of that you're expecting it
that's just part of the nominal
environment now on earth our society
isn't built for that right we're not are
we
we are not designed to be home
sitting inside not interacting with
other humans you know not going out and
experiencing the world around us so I
think that the the difference there is
that it's that's just not the way our
society is built and so to me it really
feels much more isolating here to know
that they're all there are all those
things that I could be doing you know I
could be out you know hiking in the
forest but I can't do those things right
now so I think that makes a little bit
more difficult you have I know in in
high school you said that your future
plan was to to go for a spacewalk now
that you you did that what what are your
future plans I know that's a good
question I've wondered a lot about what
this would feel like having fulfilled
that goal of being in space of making
those space walks and now what am I
gonna do now what's next
so I don't know I I think you know for
me of course I'm really I think it's
interesting I've actually thought more
about when I can go back to space then I
have about integrating into life down on
earth I so the chance to go back is of
course an incredible draw and and
hopefully that will happen for me again
at NASA and it depends on you know what
we're I'm kind of back in line now
waiting to get assigned for another
mission so it would be great to have
another mission whether that be on a
different vehicle to the space station
again or maybe part of the Artemis
missions it would be an amazing
experience to be part of those Artemis
missions going to the moon and again
that would be that would be my choice
but I'm not really in control of those
decisions well I won't be surprised
Jessica thank you so much for taking the
time
well thanks to maquette there are
relatives tomorrow had a dog you hope us
you hope us
I am start hope you enjoyed the clip for
more interesting conversations please
hit subscribe
you